we're turning onto the economy where
there's a troubling new milestone for
drivers gas prices hit a new record
overnight according to aaa they are now
averaging more than four dollars and 37
cents a gallon that is just one of many
signs at this point of rising inflation
nancy cordes joins us now from the white
house where president biden is expected
to once again highlight plans to bring
down prices nancy good morning
good morning tonya this has basically
become a weekly endeavor at this point
the president trying to explain to the
american people what he's doing to
attempt to bring down costs for working
families polls show he's got some work
to do on that front but he's going to
argue today that the republicans who
want to control congress would do less
gas prices shot up 17 cents this past
week the relentless price surge could
prove costly in november's midterm
elections certain purchases i used to
make i just can't make them purchases no
more the rising cost of food has pushed
budgets to the brink from coast to coast
local airwaves are filled with stories
about the rising cost of everything
soaring housing prices are a sore
subject for many in south florida gas
prices in pennsylvania soar to a new
record the eastern plains is filled with
farmers feeling the pinch in this tight
economy
the issue is now dominating president
biden's agenda my top priority is
fighting inflation and lowering prices
for families the president is taking
some action releasing one million
barrels per day from the strategic
petroleum reserve to bring down gas
prices asking congress to pass clean
energy and vehicle tax credits and
boosting the fuel economy standards for
cars and trucks the typical americans
spending a hundred dollars more
a month on gasoline now than they were a
year ago moody's chief economist mark
zandy says inflation has long-term
effects forcing families to save less
for education retirement or to buy a
home i do think the pandemic will fade
and i think of the worst of the fallout
of the russian invasion of ukraine on
our economies behind us but it's not
going to
get back to anything we consider to be
normal very quickly
this has already become a top campaign
issue we are seeing ads about inflation
and loads of congressional races across
the country that's why so many politicos
are going to be watching when new
numbers are released tomorrow that
economists predict could indicate a
slight slowing of inflation in the past
month nate
nancy thank you so much